[Music]
there is a very interesting little viral
video of a cop in a on a little booty
call at the park that
has a booty call Park a booty they have
a booty call
Park you see yeah I can see what's the
address of
the so we got this is that is that a
lady and ivory yep is searching her what
are they doing no they're making out
they're making out heavy
petting searching yo
what she like ad there just the voices
of kids in the background yeah and the
recorders are his back he doing it that
open huh he's investigating yeah he's
like show me your practices so they get
to the back seat of the
cruiser start to see the caring the guy
all hey yo hey so there's actually two
separate videos of the same cop and the
same woman like having these little
rendo at the park link up and oh
different days once this got exposed it
dug up the funniest
situation wait we know what happened
already Yes with amazing quotes I just
cannot wait to share it with you guys
yeah so uh what happened is uh basically
the cop was married oh she was the
mistress too bad she's the mistress yeah
uh but then once I guess like once the
wife had tweeted cuz like everyone was
like sending it to her whatever the wife
tweets out um like [__] this [__] blah
blah that's like that he's like cheating
with and stuff hold on I'm give me a big
ass ad um don't click it the woman like
uh the woman responds saying that like
oh this ain't some one night stand like
she says I'm living my life I have
children I'm sure as you guys know I
have a 15-year-old autistic boy his
father was Caucasian I guess I have a
thing for
caucasians in my head I've done nothing
wrong I'm going to continue living my
life doing what I'm doing in my heart in
his heart I know that I've done nothing
he knows Paula knows I've done nothing
wrong God is my higher power this is the
mistress like talking about like she's
not feeling guilty about what she did
for
her why cuz she has an autistic son and
she's horny
well it's because the autistic son got
his autism from the autistic mom we
think she did nothing
wrong no he said she someone's got to
get my
back
what that's [__] up dude I thought I
thought she was say get I white guys and
then my I have an autistic son with a
white father so I'm like are you
consistently getting autistic jeans from
white men like I don't get what she's
tring
she she's saying that it's not a big
deal also she says what's so exciting
he's a cop I'm a civilian we got caught
it sucks but this will pass she's not
the one who's cheating oh no she's not
she doesn't when the chick attacks the
the mistress it's like dude attack your
man broke so wait wait so so so she's
obviously with the dude that's cheating
a cop right get in the back of his car
and then the fact that she uses God at
the end as if that's like his calling I
got God on my side telling me these
things so I'm cool I'm going to heaven
that doesn't that's legit only God could
judge me you know so that's a good
explanation that's her name's V Virginia
Pinto I believe Pinto she's the mistress
and then the um the wife is Paula marlot
and uh so Paula responds after that and
says seems like Virginia has a mouthful
to give about me when her husband left
her dirty ass because she can't stop
cheating and inserting herself into
other people's business she said I got
go on my side Jerry Jerry Jerry Jerry
and then she says my husband used her
for sex because she was easy I never put
our marriage out there because like all
marriages we hit a rough patch we get
through everything at the end of the day
even [__] [__] my mans wow but but
homie is like being a little reckless
he's just at a park just hooking up like
probably sitting there reading Twitter
and nobody's yelling at him yeah dude
like you couldn't you couldn't be more
Incognito as a cop like in uniform seem
pretty boastful yeah right all I saw was
the department saying like they're
taking disciplinary actions or whatever
and I was like probably on the girl why
so then the uh mistress responds after
that and she says get messy she says
from what what I read in the reports
allegedly in may he got suspended for
domestic violence that should prove
right there ding ding ding ding maybe
something's not great in their
relationship oh why is she burning I'm
like bars now bro she droing bars what
side is she on and she's like at the end
of the day we get through
everything even when I [__] his ass up
even our fist fights so she says now
people will understand and will see that
no marriage is perfect he just happens
to be a police officer she thinks people
are just making a big deal of it cuz
he's a cop yes he's supposed to uphold
the law he can't even uphold his own
family laws and [__] no it's cuz we
didn't know we we thought he was
questioning her some [__] and then all
of a sudden he starts making out with
her and like what the [__] going on
and then she opens the door and gets in
so seems like he's like making her do it
right you can't tell yeah I can't tell
anything it looked like some shady [__]
yeah like he was like oh is that lady
safe you don't know cuz there's like
weird like Vibes well that's a it's a
power situation I don't and they go in
in the [__] SUV start shaking like
crazy Grand the auto and he's on he's
technically on duty right if he's yeah
that car [__] on like he wants to be
seen there's like no other cars around
like you'd want to be like a little
hidden or at least under a tree or
something tree from the park and as a
cop you just stand out in general in
general dude yeah like everyone's aware
of you you're in uniform this reminds me
of the onion head girl cop who [__]
the whole department onion head onion
head girl all right the funny thing is I
immediately you know exactly what he
means that bun was high and tight that
was a white onion show the guy filming
did did he go like I'm allowed to record
you officer I'm allowed under the law
I'm allowed and we can't get down that
guy cuz that guy's just like hey yo yeah
sweet there's hella kids in the
background kids not even in the
background in the foreground man they
was just running by so there's um so the
officer I guess like they started
digging into his record they find out
that um in 2016 he was indicted for
child abuse after he spanked his
ex-girlfriend's three-year-old son so
hard that he lost Consciousness he lost
Consciousness the kid
ohus oh
[__] the fu
oh my God I get squeamish about violence
they just
go somebody get my back damn your hand
just gets hella hurt you're like oh [__]
my mind's lost he lost Consciousness
that's crazy damn yeah the boy lost
Consciousness from getting spanked how
did he not get fired then he's like well
how how much can I much worse the blue
Veil what are the standards for being a
cop dude come on bro this guy's
this guy's got domestic violence this
guy's got [__] child abuse this guy's
[__] sleeping with the other chick
twice getting caught aart you couldn't
go to the crib and now it's time for
barwan defend that cop defend that cop
defend that cop if I
were if I were to help him if I were to
help him and I was I could bring a time
machine I would go hey take her to the
longest car wash in town
do it in the car and the car wash as
it's going through the thing three
minutes and then make sure you finish
before the
[__] comes that's true you need a
time machine to go through the long car
wash no so he goes back in time he can
redo redo his steps at the park how do
you defend the cop now yeah can you help
him in the present I'm No Time Machine
let's just say you don't have a time
machine I'm like everyone needs to shut
the [__] up cuz he's undercover right
now and you're about to blow the
world close this case he's undercover in
his
uniform a detective he's just a traffic
cop he's working undercover dude double
undercover double double undercover you
know he's trying to work on he's trying
to work on
police
sex bad behavior uh-huh police sex bad
behavior that makes so much sense while
in uniform cuz he's trying to catch all
the other cops problem oh he had to see
who's the girl [__] all the cops see
double
Undercover the
girl yep it's like when when police
officers have to catch hookers right and
they pretend to be like a customer the
hooker customer and they commit they
commit they commit to the part and after
they come they go ah you're under arrest
clack yeah clack little tip out there
cop can't show you his dick he can't
really it's illegal dude
yeah if you're trying to be a hooker out
there first thing you do is say take
your dick out and then if they do you're
good oh really what happens if the cop
shows his dick and he's a real cop he
might be double
undercover he might be double undercover
looking for the sex looking for the the
women who will have if they're not
circumcised is it triple undercover cuz
they're cuz they're like not covering it
cuz they're undercover I don't have the
field manual do do you think a cop has
ever accidentally got a a hooker that
was also a cop that actually happened
that did right did what happens do they
just [__] say see you work see it
work see you at the
barbecue it's a great question you think
there's ever like a you know like those
undercover gangs that they make so then
they they're like they work with like a
[__] fake yeah like a fake Sons of
Anarchy right so imagine like a FBI
versus CIA and they both come into
contact trying to catch each other but
they're both agents that's just happened
too they like arrested each other or
some [__] yeah you're under arrest
they're like no you're under arrest and
then it's like they other court called
double undercover it is isn't it like
Blue Streak I'm pretty sure it's Blue
Streak Blue Streak tring find the jewel
thought it was National Security yeah it
was cuz there's FBI and cops yeah yeah
they found each other was that Martin
Lawrence descript of a movie from F yeah
fat I remember was it Martin Lawrence
that was yeah so was Black Knight if you
wanted to
know